Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
此外，还有丰厚的奖品等着你，由Lisa亲自颁发。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. And today we're going to be thinking about compassion. Now compassion is something that I think would have made my journey to being a clinical psychologist a whole heck more enjoyable had I discovered the practice of compassion before I actually did. So first off, I will tell you when I first kind of connected with compassion and also the close call I had. So let's start with the close call to begin with. is by Professor Paul Gilbert, who I have had the absolute joy of meeting for a two-day course. And I got there first. There was just him and I think just him and me in the room. And he came up to me and greeted me so warmly, including a handshake. This is pre-COVID times.
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。今天我们要探讨的是“同情心”。我认为，如果我在临床心理学家的职业道路上更早发现同情心的实践，我的旅程会愉快得多。首先，我会告诉大家我最初是如何接触到同情心的，以及我经历的一次“惊险时刻”。让我们先从那次惊险时刻说起。那是Paul Gilbert教授的课程，我有幸参加了他为期两天的课程。我到得很早，房间里当时似乎只有我和他。他走过来，非常热情地迎接我，还和我握了手。这是在新冠疫情之前。
And I had just walked from a train station in winter and I was absolutely freezing. And I felt so self-conscious of how cold my hands were. And also just completely like a rabbit in the headlights for the fact that Paul Gilbert was in front of me, you know, greeting me, welcoming me along to his course. And I also was thinking this course was going to be, you know, pretty massive. There was going to be loads of people in the room. And I was just hoping to blend in, really, and to just sit in the background and soak up his Professor Paul Gilbert brilliance. But it didn't turn out that way. There was probably only about 10 of us on there. And so it was a really intense day. It was a real privilege, you know, a real privilege. I loved it. And I learned so much but my first brush with Professor Paul
我当时刚从冬天的火车站走过来，冷得要命。我对自己冰冷的手感到非常局促不安。而且，面对Paul Gilbert本人，我感觉自己就像被车灯照住的兔子一样，完全不知所措。他正在迎接我参加他的课程。我原本以为这门课会非常盛大，房间里会有很多人。我当时只想融入人群，坐在后面，吸收Paul Gilbert教授的智慧。但事实并非如此，现场大概只有10个人左右。所以那是非常紧张的一天。这真是一种荣幸，一种真正的荣幸。我非常喜欢它，也学到了很多，但我第一次接触Paul Gilbert教授是在……
Gilbert was when I was um training um it might even been shortly after I was training but I was at a house party for um for someone on my cohort and these house parties I don't know how old you are listening to this um listening to this podcast episode but this is not like a house party like it was when I was at undergrad uni you know where you don't really know the person who's hosting it you know you stay up all night um you know you have the time of your life, you drink some drink that's kind of orange that's come out of a punch bowl, but you don't really know what's in it. And you know, right now that might trigger you as well, because I know there's all sorts of drink spiking things around. But, you know, growing up, this is the late 90s and early 2000s is when I was doing my undergrad um you know I have very fond memories
我当时正在接受培训，可能是在培训后不久，我参加了同期学员举办的家庭聚会。我不知道听这期播客的你多大了，但这不像我本科时参加的那种家庭聚会，你甚至不知道主人是谁，整晚不睡觉，玩得尽兴，喝着从大碗里盛出来的、不知道成分的橙色饮料。现在这可能会让你感到警惕，因为我知道到处都有饮料被下药的事情。但对我来说，那是90年代末和21世纪初，我读本科的时候，我有非常美好的回忆。
and thankfully I came through it unscathed apart from you know drinking too much vodka and coke and things like that at some times I don't even know why I did that because I don't like um coke really so anyway so um yes I was at this house party, which definitely didn't involve bowls of punch, but probably did involve, you know, stuffed vine leaves. It was that kind of party, but lovely. And on the sideboard in my friend's house, there was a copy of the very weighty tome, you know, Compassionate Mind by the said Professor Paul Gilbert. And it had been returned by someone who had read it. And they said, Marianne, would you like to read it? And I took one look at it, saw how thick it was. And I was like no thanks I wasn't really into reading like um you know workbooks for pleasure I thought it would be really really worky and actually when I came to read it this would have been probably 2010 2011 but I didn't come on to get to grips with compassionate theory until 2017, 2018, I'm going to say.
谢天谢地，我安然无恙地度过了那段时光，除了有时喝了太多伏特加兑可乐。我甚至不知道为什么要那样做，因为我其实并不喜欢可乐。总之，我参加了那个家庭聚会，肯定没有大碗的潘趣酒，但可能有酿葡萄叶卷。那是一种很棒的聚会。在我朋友家的餐边柜上，放着那本厚重的书——《同情心思维》（Compassionate Mind），作者正是那位Paul Gilbert教授。那是别人读完后还回来的。他们问我：“Marianne，你想读读看吗？”我扫了一眼，看到它那么厚，就说：“不，谢谢。”我当时并不喜欢为了消遣而阅读工作手册，我觉得那会非常枯燥。事实上，我直到2010年或2011年才读到它，但我真正掌握同情心理论是在2017年或2018年左右。
And, you know, had I had it in my life for that many years in the middle bit and for the bit before I actually got on to the clinical training course I think it would have been super useful for me and I'd have had a much gentler ride because something I know that will resonate with many aspiring psychologists is that we can be our own harshest critic and I think this fits in with some of the you know the pop psychology around us being wounded healers you know we're partly healing ourselves by entering into this profession. And I certainly think that it's really, you know, the best job in the world. I feel so grateful, so lucky to do this that I really love, you know. So it doesn't feel like work a lot of the time, which is just, you know, I'm very lucky in that regard I think and I know that um many of you might feel the same as well um but we can it can definitely ebb and flow you know sometimes it
你知道，如果我在那中间的几年里，以及在我进入临床培训课程之前就拥有它，我想它对我会有很大帮助，我的路也会走得更顺畅。因为我知道，许多有抱负的心理学家都会产生共鸣的一点是，我们往往是自己最严厉的批评者。我认为这与我们周围关于“受伤的疗愈者”的流行心理学观点相吻合，我们通过进入这个行业，在某种程度上也在疗愈自己。我当然认为这是世界上最好的工作。我感到非常感激，非常幸运能做这份我真正热爱的工作。所以很多时候它感觉不像是在工作，我觉得在这方面我非常幸运。我知道你们中的许多人可能也有同样的感受，但这种感觉肯定会有起伏，有时……
feels a lot more worky than others and you know we get those real golden nuggets of just incredible connection and knowing where you've made such a difference to the lives of people you've worked with which is just you know incredibly wonderful so yeah part of our wounded healer mentality can be that actually you know we're quite mean to ourselves at times so discovering self-compassion for me earlier in the process if I had picked up that weighty weighty book off that sideboard along with you know some posh dip and yeah stuffed vine leaf then it might have been really useful for me and I think it would have been really useful for me as a new parent as well to have already welcomed self-compassion into my life so if you don't know you're not familiar with books on self-compassion then I'd absolutely recommend the one by Professor Paul Gilbert, but also Dr. Chris Irons, the Compassionate Mind Approach to Difficult Feelings.
感觉比其他时候更像是在工作。我们确实会获得那些宝贵的时刻，感受到不可思议的连接，知道自己在所服务的人的生活中产生了怎样的影响，这真是太美妙了。所以，我们“受伤的疗愈者”心态的一部分可能就是，我们有时对自己太苛刻了。如果我早点在那个餐边柜上拿起那本厚重的书，配上一些高档蘸酱和酿葡萄叶卷，那对我来说可能真的很有用。我想，作为一名新手父母，如果能早点将自我同情引入生活，也会非常有帮助。如果你不熟悉关于自我同情的书籍，我绝对推荐Paul Gilbert教授的那本，还有Chris Irons博士的《同情心思维应对困难情绪的方法》（The Compassionate Mind Approach to Difficult Feelings）。
That's the one that I really think is really accessible and really useful. So do check out those as a first port of call if you get if this piques your interest I would say so yeah they're really useful books and had I discovered this when I was a parent you know I would have absolutely cut myself more slack you know it's hard to do any job well let alone be a new parent who you know at one point I was waking up like 37 times a night with a screaming baby. You know, it's kind of tricky. It's kind of tricky if you've got high expectations upon yourself. So, you know, the reality is certainly if you have clinical psychology in your sights, that there aren't, you know, limitless places available. So I'm just taking a quick look at
那是我认为非常易懂且非常有用的书。如果这引起了你的兴趣，我建议你把这些书作为首选。它们真的很有用。如果我在为人父母时就发现了这一点，我绝对会对自己宽容一些。做好任何工作都很困难，更不用说作为一个新手父母了。我曾经有一段时间每晚要醒来37次去照顾哭闹的婴儿。如果你对自己期望过高，那确实很棘手。现实情况是，如果你瞄准了临床心理学，名额并不是无限的。我正在快速浏览一下……
the book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective here. And, you know, the success rates and the number of places, it's, you know, it's pretty sobering reading. So across the UK, funded places in 2021 were 979 with the applicants being 4544 so the success rate that year was 22 percent and of course it is a little skewed because people will be applying who maybe have only just graduated and so it would be less likely that they would be successful. So actually, if you do have a number of years experience, and you might perhaps have a master's and done some published research, then actually your chance of success might be higher than 22%. Does that make sense? But yeah, the number of places was 979. And it was always, you know, on my radar how many places there were on the course that I wanted to apply for. And because I was doing my assistant psychologist roles in the Midlands.
《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。成功率和名额数量读起来确实让人清醒。在英国，2021年的资助名额为979个，申请人数为4544人，当年的成功率为22%。当然，这个数据有点偏差，因为申请者中可能有人刚毕业，成功的可能性较低。实际上，如果你有几年的工作经验，可能还有硕士学位并发表过研究成果，那么你成功的几率可能会高于22%。这有道理吗？但名额确实只有979个。我一直关注着我想申请的课程有多少名额，因为我当时在米德兰兹担任助理心理学家。
So, you know, the course that I ended up getting on, happily loving, had 15 places, one, five five the year that I was successful and so it was always in my mind you know if I help someone too much or if I you know am too graceful and useful here, I could be talking myself out of a place and giving it to, you know, to them, which, oh, it's a really difficult, difficult position, because, you know, I adore my friends, I'm still in contact with many of them now. And yet, you know, it's difficult, isn't it being a human, but also, you know, we've got this survival instinct, you know, at that point, if I'd had to choose who I prefer to get on a course, then I would have had to put in my secret ballot box, rather than raising my hand, me, I'd rather I got on to training, you know, and that's difficult because we want to have a really collaborative ethos, you know, and I think this is more commonly spoken about now, about how to,
我最终考上的那个课程，我非常喜欢，在我成功的那一年有15个名额。所以我一直记在心里：如果我帮别人太多，或者表现得太优雅、太有用，我可能会把自己挤掉，把名额让给别人。这真是一个非常困难的处境，因为我深爱我的朋友们，我现在仍与他们中的许多人保持联系。然而，做人真的很不容易，对吧？而且我们有这种生存本能。在那一刻，如果我必须选择谁能考上，我不得不把票投给自己，而不是举手让别人上。这很困难，因为我们想要一种真正协作的精神。我认为现在人们更常谈论这一点，关于如何……
you know, how to remain compassionate to yourself and to others and actually, you know know there is room for everybody um to do well and to you know to try and be their optimal best and that um you know this is something that my children struggle with as well so my children are eight and five um you know if i say to one of them oh gosh you know you've done that beautifully what a wonderful picture what a lovely little artist you are or um you know I might say oh god you're so funny oh that's really made me laugh the other one will say I suppose I'm not funny or I suppose I'm a terrible artist and it's like no that's not true you, I try to introduce them to the concept of mutual exclusivity, which is a hard sell. We're just going to pause for this quick ad break here. And hopefully by the time we get back, we will find that you are less of a hard sell than the eight year old andyear-old are in terms of mutual exclusivity. Ooh, our Tricky Brain Kit.
如何保持对自己和他人的同情，实际上每个人都有空间去取得成功，去努力达到最佳状态。这也是我的孩子们所挣扎的事情。我的孩子分别是八岁和五岁。如果我对其中一个说：“天哪，你画得真漂亮，你真是个了不起的小艺术家。”或者说：“天哪，你太幽默了，真的把我逗笑了。”另一个就会说：“那我不幽默吗？”或者“那我是个糟糕的艺术家吗？”这不对。我试图向他们介绍“互斥”的概念，但这很难推销。我们先暂停一下插播广告。希望等我们回来时，你会发现你比那两个八岁和五岁的孩子更容易接受“互斥”这个概念。哦，我们的“棘手大脑工具包”（Tricky Brain Kit）。
It's a kit and a course that helps you work with those that have depression or trauma. Ooh, our Tricky Brain Kit really helps me as a clinician to bring the compassion-focused therapy to life in a way that my clients can really engage with and remember. So, yeah, I'd recommend it. A Tricky Brain Kit A Tricky Brain Kit It's a kit and a course that helps you work with those that have depression or trauma. Oh, our tricky brain kit. So, as you might know, mutual exclusivity is the concept that things, you know, can only operate a bit like a train track. So they can only operate as a parallel, you know. So if I was a good artist, then it would mean someone else couldn't
这是一个工具包和课程，旨在帮助你与患有抑郁症或创伤的人一起工作。我们的“棘手大脑工具包”确实帮助我作为临床医生将同情心聚焦疗法（CFT）生动地呈现出来，让我的客户能够真正参与并记住它。所以，我推荐它。“棘手大脑工具包”，它是一个工具包和课程，帮助你与患有抑郁症或创伤的人一起工作。哦，我们的棘手大脑工具包。正如你可能知道的，互斥是一个概念，即事物只能像火车轨道一样运作。它们只能平行运作。所以，如果我是个优秀的艺术家，那就意味着别人不能……
be a good artist. But of course, we know that those are not mutually exclusive concepts. We know that actually, it's quite possible for people to be for lots of people to be very good at art and and for our you know our artistic style to apply and appeal to different people as well so some may say that I was the better artist they'd be wrong because I'm dreadful and others you know beauty is in the eye of the beholder and all of that others might think that um, someone else is a better artist and they would likely be right because my art is abysmal. So, yes, I picked a bad example, but my kids like drawing. So that's a really nice thing. skills and you know experiences to offer and useful you know useful techniques and things about me that makes me a good psychologist but you can also have the same techniques skills and
成为优秀的艺术家。但我们当然知道，这些并不是互斥的概念。我们知道，实际上很多人完全可以擅长艺术，我们的艺术风格也可以适用于不同的人。有些人可能会说我是更好的艺术家，他们错了，因为我画得很烂。而其他人——美在观察者的眼中——可能会认为别人是更好的艺术家，他们很可能是对的，因为我的艺术水平糟透了。所以，我选了一个糟糕的例子，但我的孩子们喜欢画画。这真是一件好事。技能和经验，以及作为心理学家的有用特质，使我成为一名优秀的心理学家。但你也可以拥有相同的技能和……
experiences or different techniques skills and experiences and you can also be you know good psychologist too because we have to be able to you know hold space for for others also doing good things and know that that doesn't detract from from our own experience and our own validity and our own worth gosh these are all terms that we learn about in psychology undergrad aren't they validity and you know ecological validity and normality and on all of that and actually here I am using them to talk to you so you know the stuff we learn undergrad and the stuff we learn at a level if you did it it's super useful you know, the stuff we learn undergrad and the stuff we learn at A-level, if you did it, it's super useful, you know, and actually. I still use many of the techniques in the theory that I learned at A-level now, you know, so, you know, bystander effect and cognitive dissonance and things like that, you know, they're really integral, integral concepts. So anyway, that's a bit of an aside, isn't it? But in terms of compassion, you know, we can allow ourselves to, to be good enough and to know that we,
经验，或者不同的技能和经验，你也可以成为一名优秀的心理学家。因为我们必须能够为他人留出空间，做好的事情，并知道这并不会削弱我们自己的经验、有效性和价值。天哪，这些都是我们在心理学本科学习中接触到的术语，对吧？有效性、生态效度、常态等等。实际上，我正在用它们与你交谈。所以，我们在本科和A-level阶段学到的东西真的非常有用。我至今仍在使用我在A-level阶段学到的许多理论技巧，比如旁观者效应、认知失调等，它们是非常核心的概念。总之，这有点跑题了，对吧？但就同情心而言，我们可以允许自己做到“足够好”，并知道我们……
you know, we can't expect ourselves to be a genius at psychology, if we are indeed, you know, starting out, if we've not done it before we have to be able to give ourselves you know the the breathing space and the capacity and the um you know the permission but also the the kindness really to not get things right first time every time and that cropped up recently for me on my second ever salsa lesson um because I was just not very good um but realistically I was comparing myself to people who'd been doing it for years and were asking me to dance and spinning me around like you you know, like I was on Strictly. And so, you know, I was never going to come up very well, you know, and it actually did take me sort of an hour or so
我们不能指望自己成为心理学天才，如果我们确实是刚起步，如果之前没做过的话。我们必须能够给自己留出呼吸的空间、能力，以及许可，还有真正的善意，不必第一次就事事完美。这最近在我的第二次萨尔萨舞课上就出现了，因为我表现得不太好。但现实地讲，我是在拿自己和那些跳了多年的人比较，他们邀请我跳舞，像在《舞动奇迹》里那样旋转我。所以，我注定表现不会太好。实际上，我花了一个小时左右……
until I was home to think, hold on, Marianne, come on. It's all right. You can't expect yourself to be an expert on your second lesson. It's okay if your feet were a bit of a mess. It's okay if you were, you know, feeling a bit overwhelmed a mess it's okay if you were you know feeling a bit overwhelmed at times that's all right because actually the people teaching you stuff we're teaching you quite complicated moves um and when even the basic steps are kind of taking some some headspace and some thinking it's okay to find the you know the complicated ones um a little bit perplexing as well so I am going back for um for lesson three um next week and you know I may still be rubbish I likely will be and my dancing is about as good as my artistry um but I'm all right with that you know because I'm never going
直到回到家才想：“等等，Marianne，冷静点。没关系。你不能指望自己在第二节课就成为专家。脚下乱一点没关系。感到有点不知所措也没关系。”因为教你东西的人教的是相当复杂的动作。当连基本舞步都需要占用脑力和思考时，觉得复杂的动作有点令人困惑也是正常的。所以我下周还要去上第三节课。我可能还是很烂，很可能会这样。我的舞技和我的艺术水平差不多，但我对此没意见。因为我永远不会……
to be a professional dancer believe me I am never going to be that you know so I can both be a good psychologist and a terrible dancer you know because the two are not mutually exclusive like I you know I wouldn't have to be one or the other so yeah I would just allow yourself to appreciate where you are right now and to not be able to you know for example be expecting yourself to be a complete neuropsych wizard if you've never done neuropsych before um you know i remember when i was an assistant psychologist um i'd done um some neuropsych with a client and we were concerned about some of his functioning. And it involved sort of drawing a clock face.
成为一名专业舞者，相信我，我永远不会成为那样的人。所以我既可以是一名优秀的心理学家，也可以是一名糟糕的舞者，因为这两者并不互斥。我不必非此即彼。所以，我建议你允许自己欣赏现在的状态，不要指望自己能成为神经心理学专家，如果你之前从未接触过神经心理学的话。我记得我做助理心理学家时，曾和一位客户做过一些神经心理学测试，我们担心他的一些功能。测试涉及画一个时钟表盘。
And my supervisor just really briefly came into the office afterwards and said, oh, look, you can see that he might have some visual impairment because he's only done it on one side or he's got some sort of planning problems or ran out of space. And I just thought, oh, yeah, I didn't really see that. I didn't really get that when I saw that. And I felt like, oh, she's so good. And she is, you know, but I've never done it before, you know. And so actually, I wasn't used to making, you know, interpretations and trying to formulate about this particular, you know, piece of neuropsych or particular piece of, you know, theory. And so just allowing yourself some breathing space to allow yourself to grow, water yourself and allow yourself to just, you know, do what you need to do and to know that you're, you know, you are supposed to be learning. You know, even when we are fortunate enough to get places on declenside courses or whatever course it is that you're aspiring to, we are not expected to know it all because we're not
我的主管事后简短地走进办公室说：“哦，你看，你可以看出他可能有视觉障碍，因为他只画了一侧，或者他有某种规划问题，或者空间不够了。”我当时心想：“哦，是的，我没看出来。”我当时没意识到。我觉得她太厉害了。她确实很厉害，但我之前从未做过这些。所以，我当时还不习惯做出解释，也不习惯尝试对这特定的神经心理学片段或理论进行构思。所以，给自己留出一些呼吸空间，让自己成长，滋养自己，允许自己做需要做的事情，并知道你本就处于学习阶段。即使我们有幸进入临床心理学课程或任何你向往的课程，我们也不被期望知道一切，因为我们……
supposed to be the finished article. I feel like this is a massive topic and we might well need to do another episode on this. And if you think that'd be useful, give me a shout. Please do, you know, subscribe and review and yeah, keep listening and let me know any feedback you've got and i will look forward to catching up with you on our next episode take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll say you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne
不应该是成品。我觉得这是一个巨大的话题，我们可能需要再做一期节目来探讨。如果你觉得有用，请告诉我。请务必订阅并留下评论，继续收听，并让我知道你的任何反馈。我期待在下一期节目中与你交流。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南，通过这个播客，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》，我是Marianne博士。
my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的不同故事非常有趣。我惊讶于通往这一目标的途径如此之多，没有完美的路径。这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。